we are here with I'll call you the man
the myth the legend bigad himself is
here I mean what I love about you my
friend is that you have become already a
standout superstar in the 90 day fiancé
franchise I'm Edie I'm 54 years old
people know me as Big Ed I'm from San
Diego California and I am a professional
photographer I actually gave myself the
name Big Ed perfect because I have a
huge personality and it makes me feel
tall well you've always been big at this
was a persona you've had your whole
adult life right absolutely I mean you
gave yourself that name I did I was
waiting tables at a restaurant at San
Diego and and I through college and I
just came up with the idea of calling me
so big yet put it on my name badge next
thing you know there's a wait to city
mice in my section every Friday night
and it just grew and then later on I got
a job in architecture and we went in to
get the big job and the CEO is like your
Big Ed you serve me shots of tequila and
we got the big contract so they my boss
said put that on your business cards
love it big Edie and maybe the shots of
tequila think perhaps yeah so you have
kind of always been this big personality
did you want to go on TV how did getting
on before the 90s happen first of all I
never heard of the show all I did was I
fell in love with a girl on Facebook
bought a ticket and posted that online
and I just started to get millions of
messages or hundreds of messages you
know are you doing 90 day and I'm like
no what is that
my buddy rich sent me a link I filled it
out within two hours I was on the phone
with casting Pam and the rest is history
I mean it's and Here I am Wow so they
they saw something special in what you
guys had going on right away what did
what do you think made you the right fit
for the show um that's a very good
question because I don't consider myself
very attractive I'm not tall I can't
believe this girl's in love with me I
just wanted to tell my story you know I
just wanted to be real I mean cuz I'm
like this I mean I do crazy things all
the time I somewhat of a gamer so I fall
asleep
while gaming with all these people
around the world and people start
following me it's just I'm a natural
goof but I'm I've always been able to
laugh at myself yeah well you got to
tell me what you're holding here themed
these okay so this is the one and only
Big Ed sticker I want to give you your
own these are all over the world they're
in Australia they're in Russia people
have them on their water bottles people
send me pictures people send me requests
for the sticker it's just me promoting
Who I am which is this kind of this like
I don't this short guy that has you know
a kind of a chubby face and whatever
Here I am I just
I'd like to make people laugh and I
always have and and that's I know this
is Who I am
so his rows gonna get her own sticker
rose got her own sticker oh she has yes
oh yeah
it's so did her sister oh they're all
over the Philippines - well that must be
meaningful if they got the sticker it is
that's nice thank you for this I'm gonna
keep this this you know what we're gonna
put this in one of our cameras we're
gonna call that camera the Big Ed I love
it
geez I'm getting ready to get on a plane
and go meet rose the love of my life for
the very first time I also bought a ring
and I planned to ask rose to marry me so
you you get on the show you get cast on
the show and did you have any hesitation
because with this show there are major
fans and there are major criticisms that
come at people right well other than my
daughter hanging up on me and she didn't
speak to me for a whole month and a lot
of pushback from my mom all my friends
they like Edie this is not a good idea
your life is gonna be exposed and at
first I was like very hesitant but I was
in love this wasn't about the show it
was about me going to meet the love of
my life I've been single for 28 years
and I was open to love again and and
then I'm on TV
so what it's it was kind of surreal I
mean you've had some moments already we
got it your hair is pulled back today
but we have to talk about the mayonnaise
oh my god and who told you to put the
mayonnaise here my co-workers husband
this guy raccoon brand he is amazing
he's my best friend
he well she actually told me that he
does it is there mayonnaise in your hair
today
no ma'am okay you would smell it oh but
I'll tell you this right now it works it
absolutely works you I do smell like an
egg salad sandwich when I'm done so you
have to make sure you that you wash it
out but you know what I loved about it
was we saw you putting the mayonnaise in
and you just had a glass of red wine
with you you were just doing your beauty
treatment this was just your normal real
life I felt this isn't put on for the
show he's really doing this oh I do it
and by the way that red wine was Malbec
my favorite so you any other beauty tips
or tricks that you have that you will be
sharing with the world or that you want
to share with us now well I just got out
of here and makeup so I look good now um
I just know I am I'm not a real pretty
person I do I get my eyebrows they they
use the thread which is so painful so I
do that and I get my my mani-pedi I know
that's weird bite it now it works
keep it ground and then the mayonnaise
you know it's do you have a favorite
brand
I think crafted okay
my go-to mayonnaise did rose no but do
you call road you go phony my rose my
color rose call Rosie
well actually I call him my queen and
she calls me her King and her son is
Prince how do you make that up it's it's
the truth yeah I mean you're sitting I
know we've got to see what happens on
the show but you're sitting here seeming
like a pretty happy guy today I am and I
got a bigger house yes we saw that I
named Instagram yeah I gotta take care
of my mom she's amazing 81 years old and
nurse my best friend in the whole world
okay so we're gonna see what unfolds
with you and your love story yes what
can we expect because there have already
been some big ups and downs and major
emotional moments what I can tell you is
it is a roller coaster it is the most
surreal experience that I've ever done
in my life that I'll probably ever do in
my life and you have to stay tuned it's
gonna get crazy good crazy did Rose know
that you put mayonnaise in your hair
Rose did not know it but he's in oh yes
she does
I think the world knows yeah uh you I
mean lucky you were this guy who so
quickly came across as a guy with a big
heart I mean that moment when you sent
that video to your daughter yeah in case
something happened and you got on the
flight that was really really
heartbreaking to watch you know god
forbid something should ever happen to
me I want you to know that I love you
you're the best thing that I've ever
created in this world and you'll always
be my number one what was it like for
you to watch that matically cry um it
was tough I mean it was tough for 29
years I've never got on a plane without
talking to my daughter
it's just our thing and I it just hit me
all at once I'm like oh my god here I'm
going you know flying 7,000 miles you
know across the world and and I knew she
was mad at me
you know I hadn't talked to her for
about a month and and I just reached out
to her and it just made the trip
worthwhile say that what would it have
been like if you hadn't been able to
speak to your daughter before you think
it would have been it's hard to enjoy
yourself you know what I mean enjoy life
when the people you love the most are
hurting and that was tough that would
have been tough but I think what touched
me the most was in the video when you
said you're always my number one and
she's just like your dad she's a pain in
the butt she is stubborn and her mom
told her that all the time you're just
like your father but we're two peas in
the pod she's beautiful she is like I
said she's the best thing I've created
in this world weird
how hard was that for you that your
daughter wasn't talking to you that you
were finding this love you've been
looking for for years but your number
one was not even on speaking terms with
you yeah so I'm as I'm close with my mom
but any father out there that has a
daughter and a single parent I raised my
Ari Stephanie since she was 1 I wasn't a
part-time dad she went to school with me
she we hung out we were besties and
she's the number one person in my life
and she's mad at me so it was like this
you know ending of a marriage kind of
thing like where you know she's hurt and
I didn't understand why and the main
reason why she was hurt because you know
I'm a man and we don't listen all the
time but I wasn't listening to her she
was hurting and she was sending me texts
saying ed this is a bad idea or dad
don't do this but I wasn't listening and
that hurt her more than anything
so we're better now yeah yeah and when I
learned a lot from that experience -
anything you would have done differently
looking back with the way that you
brought rose into your life and
explained it all to your daughter I
don't think I could have made a better
fool of myself I really don't I mean
it's just I just
well I when you're in love you're not
you're not thinking you're not thinking
about anybody else but yourself
and the person that you're in love with
so you know and I was frustrated because
nobody understood it like my daughter
didn't understand it she's like that
she's 23 I'm like I know but you don't
understand what it feels like to be you
know admired after 28 years it was such
a wonderful feeling and I didn't had
that in years so well of course people
who love you want to protect you and
they look at you and say this is going
too fast you don't know this person
looking back do you think you fell in
love too fast no no no yeah no I didn't
I know I mean I went and bottled I you
bought that ring I know a bit well I
gotta call you out though because here's
what I would you love about this show is
that you see how people can fall in love
and maybe they maybe they don't make
every decision right and look people are
saying
you didn't really tell them this woman
the truth about your height you didn't
tell her the truth about wanting to have
kids or not so how do you feel about
those criticism well well first of all
one thing that needs to be corrected I
just measured myself I went to for a
checkup and with shoes I'm 5 foot and a
half inch ok so can you please yeah so
no so I was not completely honest iliza
liar so I wasn't completely honest with
Rose about that and a couple other
things and that I'm that that you know
you're yeah it's it's never a good idea
to to lie it says you know you have to
be honest and I learn I'm learning that
you know even though you have strong
feelings for somebody it's better you
know to get it out in the open
mm-hmm if not it's gonna come back and
bite you did it come back and bite you
oh yeah what are we gonna see happening
just wait okay I'm already being bitten
if you've been online I've already been
well yeah how are you feeling about that
again this this show comes with a rabid
fan base and the critics do come you're
the the stars of it right so um I have a
condition it's a syndrome called kfs
it's clip will file syndrome where
you're born with they call multiple
birth and out anomalies so instead of
having seven sort of Kolbert of rays I
have two I've three that there that are
the size of I've three that are the size
of two and so I've limited range of
movement of a bigger than normal chest
cavity so I've been made fun of all my
life and when I was in high school I
actually got stuck in the neck machine I
used to work out with all the football
players and so that became kind of a
running joke so I sort of became you
know really well-known so people would
but it would still tease me and they
would call me no neck and no neck add
and yada yada yada so when the show
first came out I was literally in a
panic because I was reading stuff online
which they told me not to and and that's
all it was was I can't wait till next
season but then about two weeks ago I
get this letter from Abe in New York
that asks my same condition and and I
was able to reach out to him and he's
like look I don't know how you do it
you're on national TV rubbing mayonnaise
in your hair I have the same problem
everybody's making fun of me
he wants to give up on life and I just
said you know a do not do not let this
syndrome to find who you are and that's
kind of how I've always lived my life
and I even asked my ex-wife one time who
I met the time we got married was
beautiful and I said um you know why do
you love me don't you do don't I look
different to you that I have a shorter
neck and I'm not very tall and she's
like what are you talking about so and
then there's another funny story I was
used to doing home sales and I was
sitting in a dining room table and the
sort of four year old girl comes with me
goes comes up to me goes can I sketch
you I'm like absolutely and she draws
this box which is my body and it had
arms and legs and then she drew another
box on top of that box with a smile and
when I looked at it I just started
laughing and I I go can I keep this and
what I learned from that experience was
that she wasn't trying to be mean she
was just drawing who she saw that I was
so if we can learn more to laugh at
ourselves and understand that people are
gonna look at us differently but the
most important thing that I learned from
that is is that that I'm different and
it's okay to be different do you think
that if you I'm going back to you know
the moment when you first meet rose yes
how much have things changed from when
she saw you then and when some of this
stuff comes out like the truth about
things she sees you in person for the
first time to where you're at now have
you guys had a lot of growth since then
I know you can't tell me everything but
if that's it's a lot for her to process
yeah it is and we're in a really good
place that's all I could say okay ed do
you have a message for people who have
been unkind to you about your appearance
yeah you know what
and I think if people really knew how it
affects people when you make fun of
somebody they wouldn't do it you know
they wouldn't window to make some
summons to make fun of somebody's
physical appearance
is it's it's an unkind thing but I'm not
mad at them they're just like that
little girl she they're just looking at
me and seeing me how they see me yeah
but I fate knew it's not a good idea
yeah so you've got your little dog in
your life as well Ted oh my god Wow has
he seen himself on TV he's like you know
what I'm starting to get a little bit
jealous because people will see us in
public and they're like oh my god your
dog is so cute I saw him on TV I'm like
oh okay I was right next to him yeah so
he's wonderful he's my little buddy um
are you gonna expand the family anymore
what can you tell us oh my god what are
you trying to do I'll get in trouble if
I tell the only thing I can tell you
it's gonna be exciting it's gonna be a
lot of fun a lot of heartbreak bottom
emotions just you got to pay attention
you gotta watch the show well will we
see any issues in the relationship that
you've experienced before you talked a
lot about being unfaithful in your
marriage and how you regretted that did
you learn from that do you still
struggle with that no I'm struggling
with and I think the reason why I've
been single for so many years is you put
up a wall and there's two things that
you have to deal with when you you have
heartbreak one is can I trust the other
person and then can I trust myself the
only thing I can say is I've grown up
I've learned a lot it was a stupid
mistake
and I got a beautiful daughter out of it
I've had a wonderful life and now I met
rose and you know the rest is gonna be
good history the rest is gonna be good
TV yeah there you go
are you in love right now yes so what
can you tell us about where things are
at right now
well I'm about to meet rose in the
airport for the first time so that's
what what is that moment like for you if
you take yourself back to all I can't
like you can't write this stuff but you
can't write this you know in a book of
feeling like to be in love with somebody
for three months and knowing within like
she made me wait for about 20 minutes
knowing that you're gonna see her and
you want us you know you want to feel
them and touch them and what do they
smell like and it's just that moment was
just like I can't describe it thank you
you have mayonnaise in your hair at that
moment but I did not I just thought
about it because you said what are they
smell like no no exactly didn't go in
like the egg salad sandwich that day no
ma'am but I was on a plane for 17 hours
so I don't know what I smell my I always
think that when I watch the show
everybody's trying to clean up in the
bathroom gotta be so hard to meet this
person you're so excited to meet and
you're thinking I've been just sitting
and not moving for 20 hours and I
haven't had a shower and yeah that's
gotta be tart and my hair was just my
mom keeps you know um when are you gonna
cut your hair my hair was just a mess I
mean I just you know but I was so
excited to see rose I don't care like I
didn't he is what the most emotional
moment we're gonna see from you this
season will be is it heartbreaking
is it gut-wrenching what are we gonna
face ahead I think it's gonna be a lot
of although it's gonna be you know a lot
of it's gonna be a roller coaster it's
gonna be ups and downs you know getting
to know somebody
it's and what about things with roses
family there was an issue with her
sister asking you for money
yeah did your red flags go up enough
then should you have treated that
differently oh that freaked me out I
mean her literally I was two weeks
before I'm gonna leave she texted me I
need money I'm like okay great when I
get there we'll sit down let me look at
your situation and I'll help in any way
I can
but she's like no no you have to send it
right away oh and do not tell rose so
that was weighing heavy on my mind all
the way you know that flight over it I
was thinking about that like what if
this is a scam what if Rose is in on it
and after 28 years here we go again I
failed I feel I mean so that just kept
going through my mind but um well that's
my last question for you is on these
shows that that's kind of how everybody
gets sucked into the 90-day franchise in
the first place is is this person being
scammed or is this real and what do you
want to say about you and roses
relationship okay when I what I can say
is for me this was real it was real and
you're gonna have to watch
well I mean you know but it goes both
ways I mean what do you say to people
I'm sure that you've gotten criticism
for dating a woman 30 years younger than
you younger than your daughter what do
you say to those people um well
hopefully my daughter's not listening
but for me age is a number it's what's
in the heart and that's what I I want
people to follow their heart I think
that's the most important thing and
don't be you know be smart you know but
I have no regrets
[Music]